jetzt ist es also passiert meine damen
und herren der deutsche bundestag
beschließt keine impfpflicht ab 18 keine
ab 50 keiner ab 60 man könnte sogar
sagen gar keine impfpflicht und ich will
heute echt nicht unken aber sollte der
herbst so werden wie fast alle experten
behaupten sollte also das homeschooling
sein comeback feiern und das home office
und all die anderen sachen metro merken
wir uns bitte jetzt schon wem wir das
dann verdanken werden und da geht es
wirklich nicht um persönliche plumpe
schuldzuweisung sowas ist ja immer auch
eine gruppen leistungen aber einige
haben sich da halt schon mehr hervor
getan als andere bitte merken für olaf
scholz jedenfalls war es die erste echte
niederlage seiner kanzlerschaft man
fragt sich fast schon ja regiert denn
der alte holzmichl noch nein wirklich
top idee für den koalitionsfrieden auf
einen eigenen ampel gesetzentwurf zu
verzichten ja stattdessen
fraktionsübergreifende gruppenanträge
also der plan ist aber wirklich mal voll
aufgegangen eine blamage für die
bundesregierung tatsächlich eine
schlappe für ein bitterer tag heute eine
blamage für totale blamage eine schwere
schlappe fachen niederlage kein guter
tag für herbe klatsche hier eine herbe
klatsche
so fasst es ziemlich gut zusammen die
ampel hat's verbockt mit anlauf die
impfpflicht wurde über monate zerredet
meine sicher es bleibt eine schwere
grundrechts einschränkung aber bei immer
noch 2,7 millionen ungeimpften über 60
landen selbst mit omikron im herbst sehr
wahrscheinlich noch so viele auf der
intensivstation das ist natürlich wieder
zu einschränkungen für alle kommt und
nur mal zur erinnerung ende letzten
jahres hat herr scholz die allgemeine
impfpflicht ab februar oder märz
angekündigt was sagt man dazu aber
keine angst er lacht nicht mit uns er
lacht über uns ganz wichtig und die
opposition hat sich gestern genau so
blamiert natürlich cdu und csu lassen
die impfpflicht nämlich nicht aus
überzeugung vor die wand laufen damit
könnte ich vielleicht noch leben sondern
nur um die ampel scheitern zu sehen
kompromissvorschlag der union ein wie
war das gestufter impf mechanismus der
im notfall aktiviert würde also wenn es
zu spät ist hier bekloppt es der
vergleich des jahres
wir sagen man kann bei der frage
impfpflicht ja oder nein nicht sofort
und gleich pauschal entscheiden ich sage
ihnen das ist wie bei der frage sind sie
bist du für die ehe ja oder nein da kann
man nur sagen es kommt darauf an es muss
die richtige frau da sein es muss der
richtige zeitpunkt da sein und es müssen
die umstände passen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
im pflicht ist wie die ehe vielleicht
bei ihm auf dem dorf er hat sich pixie
asmus auch sie heiraten ich meine sie
haben es ja schon vorher kaputt
gequatscht als aus einer impfpflicht ab
50 plötzlich eine ab 60 wurde grunde wir
auf dem fischmarkt
extrem vertrauenerweckend wirklich ein
kommunikations desaster nach dem anderen
aber apropos fischmarkt in hamburg darf
seit dieser woche endlich wieder
geschrieben werden
20 monate
positiv war
[Applaus]
a
alle so lang wie long beach wir fassen
kurz zusammen ab jetzt liegt die
verantwortung nur noch beim bürger bei
uns weil die politik sie nicht mehr
haben will betrifft impfen genau wie
masken pflicht zum glück sind die
meisten von uns vernunftbegabte mensch
und wenn man sich zum beispiel im
supermarkt umguckt ist die maske
eindeutig in der überzahl
die sehnsucht nach normalität haben wir
natürlich alle und keiner keiner wünscht
sich zustände wie in shanghai wo der
lockdown immer länger wird und wo kein
spaß roboter hunde durch die straßen
laufen und den menschen über
lautsprecher erklären dass sie gar
nichts dürfen außer zu hause bleiben
wie gruselig oder aber vom prinzip her
natürlich gar nicht schlecht die
bundesregierung versucht jetzt etwas
ganz ähnliches also im rahmen unserer
technischen möglichkeiten hey sie da
legt sie bitte einen mund nasen schutz
oder last zu sein das ist ab sofort ihre
private entscheidung hier beschmutzt hat
ich bereit liebe mitbürger es ist wieder
friede war ja auch nicht das macht was
draus teure bundesregierung
ganz ein feiner oder wie gesagt mehr
eigenverantwortung ist richtig solange
uns klar ist dass wir mit der impfquote
im herbst das übliche problem kriegen
andererseits ist das inzwischen ja schon
eine deutsche tradition im frühling
sprießen die krokusse und deshalb denken
wir corona ist vorbei sind genervt von
christian drosten der ist genervt von
uns und macht podcast pause dann kommt
der sommer der scheinbar nie zu ende
geht alle tragen weiße klamotten und
sehen plötzlich rattenscharf aus hier
übrigens original bilder vom steinhuder
meer dann der schock im herbst fallen
die blätter und die instanzen steigen
drosten ist super beliebt und macht
wieder seinen podcast und zack masten
pflicht sahm 2g 3g scheißen wir sind
total überrascht von dem was wieder
passiert ist weil es immer passiert
fazit deutschland braucht einen neuen
feiertag allerheiligen wird umbenannt in
alle heilige scheiße warum machen wir
eigentlich jedes jahr dieselben strophen
fehler tag
bis im sperriger name vielleicht ich
hoffe ja dass wenigstens wenigstens noch
die beratungspflicht für ungeimpfte
kommt wie finde ich echt wichtig gut
keine ahnung wie beratungsresistent die
meisten von denen sind aber fakt ist da
könnten viele neue jobs entstehen in der
beratungsbranche martin klempnow zum
beispiel hat einfach schon mal losgelegt
martin klempnow leitet im auftrag der
bundesregierung eine beratungsstelle für
ungeimpfte um skeptiker anzulocken muss
nun natürlich mit tricks arbeiten ich
kann hier nicht ein schild aufstellen wo
draufsteht impfberatung da kommt keine
sei deswegen
lade ich heute zur autogrammstunde von
wendler genial oder siehst sie können
nicht widerstehen sie kommen sofort aus
ihrem telegramm löchern ja ja ja es
wirklich da heute war ein tolles sakoa
spontaner versammeln sich die wendler
fans und ahnen nicht dass die falle gehe
jetzt zuschnappt
sie lieben
hallo freunde moment sie sind ja gar
nicht
erwartet hat sich willkommen zur
impfberatung und die türen werden jetzt
abgeschlossen
[Applaus]
das gibt dann immer ein zwei stunden
panik einer springt vielleicht sogar aus
dem fenster aber dann kann ich auch
wirklich mit der beratung anfallen das
hier das ist das rede kissen wer das
rede käsen hat der darf auch was sagen
und die anderen dürfen erst mal nicht
widersprechen ok verstanden hier
was viele nicht wissen auf den
intensivstationen liegen mehr geimpfte
als ungeimpfte tut mir leid aber das
totaler quatsch das stimmt ist totaler
quatsch nee ich stimme totaler quatsch
nicht denn du bist doch zum schluss dran
tja möchte gerne bürger und die neue
weltordnung sprechen weil natürlich die
juden
wir ziehen jetzt ganz andere saiten auf
martin klempnow zwingt seine zuhörer
sich sämtliche auftritte von karl
lauterbach bei markus lanz anzusehen
übersicht zehn stunden am stück ohne
pause ich wiederhole mein angebot
wirklich gerne noch mal da drüben sitzt
er in fast jeder der sich dazu
entschließt sich jetzt impfen zu lassen
der kann sofort nach hause gehen
okay wir verstanden also zwingt ihr mich
jetzt zum äußersten
kleiner impfstoff hoffnung
umsonst gespritzt
antec moderne
gerne auch gemixt
lasst euch penetrieren
alle machen mit
martin klempnow deutschlands letzte
hoffnung in der pandemie
martin klempnow so und dann müssen wir
natürlich noch über die tragische figur
der letzten tage reden karl lauterbach
oder wie ich sie nenne server langsam
lott
hat anfang der woche völlig überraschend
verkündet dass die isolation für positiv
getestete ab erster mai freiwillig sein
soll um es dann nur einen tag und
ungefähr 300 experten shitstorm später
wieder zurückzunehmen und sie ahnen
nicht wo er das gemacht hat also diesen
punkt also dass die infizierten
dass die sich sagen mal selbst isolieren
und nicht mehr durch das gesundheitsamt
aufgefordert werden gegenwärtig wieder
einkassieren war dass minister ja dass
man muss also was ist das jetzt die
ankündigung weil sie ja die ankündigung
wird morgen noch offiziell werden und so
weiter und so fort
was labert er den offizieller als bei
landes geht doch gar nicht inzwischen
haben wir sogar die inschrift am
reichstag geändert statt dem deutschen
volke steht er jetzt
zweitwichtigstes verfassungsorgan nach
markus lanz was ist denn los mit unserem
karlchen er hat die rücknahme seiner
isolation cd später bei twitter
bekräftigt und zwar jetzt kommt nachts
um halb drei
um die zeit wird sonst nur der besoffene
zdf-fernsehrat die pechsträhne des
carlotta macht geradezu unheimlich
[Musik]
x-factor
das unfassbare präsentiert von till
reiners
herzlich willkommen zur x-factor das
unfassbar schwachsinnige liebe zuschauer
kann es vielleicht sein und ich frage
hier nur dass auf dem
gesundheitsministerium in berlin
eventuell ein fluch leben
hier drei ex minister daniel bahr
hermann gröhe und jens spahn sagte in
einer dieser namen noch irgendetwas oder
die traurigen gesichter sehen sie
verschluckt von der bedeutungslosigkeit
als hätten sie nie existiert sie alle
sind opfer des flugs
neuester fall
wärst du doch in köln geblieben
lauterbach vor sechs monaten noch
umfragekönig menschen liebten ihn wie
freibier war ein synonym für gute
nachrichten sogar für gute
textnachrichten
der impulsive lacht ja heute lacht der
emotion nicht mehr lauterbach ist so
beliebt wie dieses altes stück graubrot
oder gibt es vielleicht zwei lauterbachs
der eine führt als professor ein
kreuzzug gegen salz im essen und weiß
haargenau auf wen oder was man hören
muss und wir brauchen eine
wissenschaftlich fundierte politik sowie
wissenschaft immer ein tolles unheimlich
habe wissenschaftlich versucht
herzuleiten wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse den rat der wissenschaft
von wissenschaftlern die wissenschaft zu
nutzen auf der grundlage der
wissenschaftlichen studien schwachsinn
ja wenn man hier ganz aufmerksam auf die
zwischentöne achtet soll man wohl auf
die wissenschaft hören und jetzt wird es
mysteriös kaum im amt hört lauterbach
nummer zwei lieber auf die fdp und hilft
mit bei der aufweichung der masken
pflicht und bitte dann die discounter
sie trotzdem für ihn durchzusetzen
sollte ihn vom lidl also eine
übernächtigte man begegnen der fragt aus
dem ohne maske das ist karl lauterbach
nachdem seine ampel fast alle maßnahmen
abschafft wittert er jetzt sollte jeder
versuchen eine infektion zu vermeiden
ist klar doktor jekyll und mister karl
beide sind opfer des
denn was die wenigsten wissen das
gesundheitsministerium wurde erbaut über
den ruinen einer alten kultstätte auf
der die germanen früher kassenpatienten
geopfert haben wie dieser
2000 jahre alte aok ausweis beweist
deshalb hat lauterbach nur noch pech im
beruf und in der liebe und geld haben
sie ergattern kann es bald keine chancen
aussichtslos keine weiteren fragen und
nächste woche bei x-factor der fluch des
verteidigungsministeriums warum jeder
der dort arbeitet in den umfragen
abgestürzt und nur noch furchtbare musik
hört das ist egal hauptsache ich höre
roland kaiser mein gott in ihrem kopf
spielt einen dämon santamaria in
dauerschleife gute nacht deutschland
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbole bei uns im neuen studio gefunden
illuminati freimaurer staatsführung ist
alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekanntgeben
er ist nicht so viele abonnenten auf
youtube
also ich würde mich ran halten